somebody's gay it's my sister you're
having a Christmas party tonight so it's
not a Christmas party
it's a nondenominational holiday mixer
more inclusive well whatever you call it
it's not happening all right it's
canceled hey idiot I'm looking right at
you okay we're not doing it
we'll still do it this branch is failing
I'm shutting you down you got to give us
a little bit of time to turn this around
all right it's by some miracle you can
close Walter Davis and his 14 million
dollar account their jobs are safe done
you'll see you're gonna look so stupid
then we'll finally have something in
common
guys what if we steal him at the
greatest time of his life at our
Christmas party tonight
this day we save a race job it's not the
worst idea Walter Dee party I used to
Edward Christmas be worth let's get
mother f-word drunk
clapping it's my birthday oh really
committing it's nice like the candle
Merry Christmas
right down the chimney close yeah
greatest party ever
hashtag open bar what are you sending
that to everyone in Chicago I'm CEOs you
know check please just drive I just
dropped all four people there at that
party tonight they gave me three stars
like a bunch of [ __ ] what did you
just say I said there were a bunch of
[ __ ]
tonight the decisions you make will have
consequences that will haunt you for the
rest of your professional life pull over
or I will shoot your penis in the face
I think he meant to swing there where'd
you get these be better if I didn't say
all cheese Forge for a holiday mixer
tonight I'm sorry you're having a
Christmas party tonight it's not
happening all right it's canceled Hey